welcome to the man of recaps this is the
hobbit trilogy years before the lord of
the rings frodo's uncle bilbo baggins
went on his own grand adventure this is
that story the first movie is an
unexpected journey where we meet the
younger bilbo baggins whose quiet
peaceful life is interrupted by gandalf
the grey coming to recruit him for an
adventure like any self-respecting
hobbit bilbo has no interest in
adventures but gandalf doesn't take no
for an answer and invites 13 dwarves
over for a dinner party where they eat
all bildo's food the leader of these
dwarves is thorin oakenshield and they
bust out some sick a cappella skills to
tell the tragic story of their long-lost
home far away at the lonely mountain was
the dwarven kingdom of erebor it was a
nice happy place and the dwarves here
were stinking rich but hoarding that
much gold attracts unwanted attention
and one day a dragon attacked yes smaug
made the mount in his home and kicked
the dwarves out they've been on the run
ever since so now it's time to take
their homeland back but of course 13
dwarves can't kill a dragon on their own
but they just found the key to the
secret back door so they can sneak in
and steal the arkanstone the super magic
gem that'll unite the dwarf clans for
this mission though we'll need an expert
burglar and that's where bilbo baggins
comes in as hobbits are naturally
stealthy bilbo turns him down once again
but the next morning he has a change of
heart he figures an adventure sounds
kind of fun soon though they're captured
by three trolls who are going to eat our
dwarves for dinner it's bilbo baggins
who talks their way out of it giving
them different ideas on how to cook
dwarves to stall for time and soon the
sun rises which wow turns the trolls to
stone as a quest reward they all get
magic swords including the mini sword
sting which bilbo would eventually pass
down to frodo but now we get a visit
from another wizard it's radagast the
brown he's kind of a hippie nature guy
who's investigating a necromancer living
in dull gould or ratagasta bro this
isn't in the books i don't have time for
this but candle didn't you hear we're
stretching this out to three movies well
then i'd better check it out speaking of
plot lines that weren't in the book are
parties being hunted by a big buff work
as og the defiler he and thorin had a
fight a while back in fact this was the
battle in which thorne picked up an oak
branch and used it as a shield got his
name thorin oakenshield so now the orcs
are on their tail it's radagast who
leads him out of there with his bunny
rabbit sled okay now the dwarves make it
to rivendell the elf city where elrond
lives but the dwarves really don't like
elves but they need his help he's the
only one that can read the map to tell
him where the secret door is that'll
only be visible on the special day so
the adventure continues but one night
they sleep in a cave that whoa's got a
trapdoor leading them down to the goblin
city where there's a massive super fat
goblin things look bleak until blam
gandolf shows up and it's a big epic
escape scene they make it out of there
but they're one person short they lost
bilbo yeah bilbo got separated right off
the bat and ended up falling to the deep
depths where what did he find but a ring
yes the one ring that would cause so
much trouble later for now though bilbo
puts it in his pocket but also down here
is the ring's current owner it's gollum
now bilbo's not much of a fighter and
gollum hasn't had company in a very long
time so they decide to play a game of
riddles bilbo wins goll will show them
the way out if he loses gollum will eat
him so with some fun times riddles in
the dark but at the end bilbo can't
think of another one he reaches in his
pocket and asks what's in my pocket
there's no way that counts as a riddle
but gollum lets it slide and he loses
but when he finds out it's the ring in
his pocket he's real mad now as bilbao
runs away he accidentally puts the ring
on and finds out it makes him invisible
he goes in for the sneak attack but
gollum is so pathetic bilbo can't bring
himself to kill him so he leaves gollum
alive a choice that would eventually
save the fate of middle earth so bible
cache is up with the dwarves like what
do you guys mean i was here the whole
time but now azog catches up with the
dwarves and it's time for him and thorne
to have their epic rematch but this time
thorin gets knocked out immediately so
it's up to the hobbit bilbo baggins to
save him and he doesn't stand a chance
but he buys enough time for the eagles
to come in yes gandalf's got those guys
on speed dial so the eagles fly our crew
to safety goodbye thank you eagles too
bad you couldn't have flown us a little
bit farther though the mountain's like a
30-minute flight for you month-long walk
for us now it's the second movie the
desolation of smog it starts right off
with our dwarves being chased by a giant
bear monster but turns out it's a
werebear named bayorn who's kind of a
nice guy but now gandalf leaves the
party to go do important wizard business
long story shorts he goes to check out
this necromancer which turns out is
sauron himself and he ends up captured
now our dwarves make their way through
merkwood forest which is a cursed forest
they get totally lost and even worse
it's full of giant spiders but wait
who's this coming to save him yeah
that's right it's legolas he's in this
movie the merc widows aren't friendly
though they arrest our gang for
trespassing and turns out legolas dad is
the elf that abandoned the dwarves when
smog attacked so thorin hates him most
of all also in this movie is a female
elf tario and if you wanted to spend a
lot of time on a dwarf elf romance
you're in luck but now invisible bilbo
is here to save the day he stages a
jailbreak where he puts them in wine
barrels and sends him down into the
river the elves are gonna stop him but
wait what's this it's an orc attack
that's not azog it's a different orc
named bog and so it is the epic barrel
riding river chase scene legolas in lord
of the rings was famous for pulling off
super cool stunts but in this movie it's
fully cgi and he's just become a video
game character in the end the dwarves
escape but now they're found by a human
bard the bowman master archer who no one
told archery was kind of legloss's thing
and so he rebrands as bard the boatman
and gives our dwarves a ride to laketown
there's a long subplot here about the
corrupt mayor and his annoying assistant
but we don't need to get into it long
story short thorin's like hey help us
get to the mountain and we'll give you
guys a share of the treasure so the
dwarves finally make it to the lonely
mountain we've got the key and the
secret back door the last light of the
moon and we're inside so it's time for
their burglar bilbo baggins to actually
do some burglaring this should be a nice
easy mission as long as you don't wake
the dragon which bilbo immediately does
once again bilbo has to talk his way out
of it by basically flattering this
dragon and smog hasn't had a visitor in
a while he's happy to chat for a bit
until he gets bored and bilbo barely
makes it out of there the dwarfs come to
back him up but they can't fight this
thing they basically gotta run and it's
a huge mountain in here they're playing
cat and mouse for about half an hour and
it somehow makes a dragon encounter
boring some of the dwarves stayed behind
though because keeley's real sick he got
hit with the orc poison arrow but now
his elf girlfriend shows up to do some
elf healing magic on him and they fall
even more in love legolas is here too he
fights bolg to give him something to do
in this movie finally the dwarves have a
plan they trick smaug into breathing
fire at the old furnaces which turns
back on then they lure him into a trap
where they unleash a torrent of molten
gold bearing smog in their shiny new
floor naturally though that doesn't work
it just made smough mad and now he's
sick of chasing dwarves around he's
gonna take his vengeance on lake town
oops so now it's time for the final
movie the battle of the five armies it
starts right off with a dragon attack
yeah burninating this whole town lake
town's only hope is our master archer
barred the bowman turns out his grandpa
was the one who tried to shoot the magic
arrow out smog the first time and
everyone thought he missed but turns out
he hit smog he knocked the scale loose
so now there's this one weakness and he
uses the magic arrow
boom slade a dragon so with smout
defeated the dwarves get their home back
and now thorin is filthy stinking rich
but now that he's rich thorin kind of
becomes a huge douchebag and not just
normal douchebaggery magical
douchebaggery called dragon sickness the
survivors of lighttown come in like hey
man you promised us some of the gold but
thorin's like i'm not giving you any not
one coin but now the elves roll up too
cause legolas's dad wants a special
necklace in there and he's willing to
fight for it meanwhile gandalf is still
in wizard jail but now who's coming to
bust him out it is lady galadriel yes
she's gonna be a main character in the
upcoming amazon series the rings of
power and she's one of the strongest
people in middle earth but she's
outnumbered because the nazgul are here
but now she gets back up from elrond
himself and a pre-evil storm on the
white so it's an epic fight scene with
the heaviest hitters in all of lord of
the rings lore which is cool but you
know kinda feels like fan fiction in the
end though soron himself shows up and
galadriel's gotta go all dark side to
blam banish his butt back to mordor with
his subplot done gandalf rejoins the
movie and speaking of irrelevant plots
there was a whole thing where bilbo
found the arkenstone but this doesn't go
anywhere but now we're ready for a big
battle it's like a thousand elves first
13 dwarves thorin's ready to fight him
but it's like bro you and what army this
army because now an army of dwarfs show
up yeah they heard the dwarves retook
the mountain it's like yeah cuz we're
here to help and so these elves and
dwarves are about to kill each other
over a misunderstanding when what's this
azzog the defiler rolls up with an orc
army the dwarves and elves put their
beef on hold as they team up to fight
the orcs yeah i don't want to tell azog
his business but if he had waited like
20 minutes his enemies would have killed
each other and thus begins the battle of
the five armies although it's unclear
what five armies there are there's the
elves of course led by liglos's dad
riding a moose and the dwarves led by
this guy riding a pig there's also the
human survivors of lake town which the
word army i think is a bit generous
they're all fighting the fourth army the
orcs led by azog the fifth army i think
are the orc reinforcements that spend
the whole battle on the way and so an
hour of messy cgi later the good guys
are about to lose but now thorin's
having a hallucination where he
overcomes his dragon sickness sorry i've
been a douche and he leads the dwarves
on a rallying charge thorne goes in for
the 1v1 with azog while our lovebirds go
in for the 2v1 with bolg but what's this
no keeley's killed they don't get a
happy ending legloss has to step in to
finish him off and he wins of course
because the laws of physics no longer
apply to him now at the end the orc
reinforcements finally arrive but good
guy reinforcements come too cause the
eagles are coming and yeah air
superiority is a really nice thing but
azog is about to beat thorin thorin's
left with no choice but to let him stab
him so that he's close enough to stab
him back by the way bilbo baggins was
nearby helping out the best he can and
now he's there for thorin's final words
and it's a tragic death but overall the
day is saved bilbo's grown from his
adventure and says goodbye to his dwarf
best friends and it's there and back
again as he makes it home to the shire
where unfortunately he discovers all
this stuff has been auctioned off cause
he was presumed dead and that's where
the hobbit trilogy comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]